Keyframing is a basic tool in the animator's box, perhaps the first one
learned. The whole idea is this: to animate an object, save its state at
various times and interpolate among these. For example, I have an object I
want to move from one position to another over time. At time A, I record the
position in time. At time B, I do the same. When I want to run the animation,
given a time, I can get the position. This is a linear interpolation between
positions A and B. The process of generating these frames in between the
keyframes is called tweening. We can do the same thing with the drinking bird,
interpolating between its two rotation angles, down and upright. Here's a set
of keyframes, A and B, and what we've shown is the times that they occur. Since
we want to loop, we give two keyframes and then we go back and repeat. A is the
bird in the down position about to go up. B is the bird in the up position
about to go down. Here's the timeline of our animation. We start with the bird
down, he goes up over two seconds and then he goes back down again over three
seconds. A is our keyframe for down, B is our keyframe for up, and they have
associated angles. We can use these two keyframes to form a loop for our
animation. One improvement we can easily add with keyframes is making the
drinking bird pause while it's drinking. We add another keyframe to our
timeline, call it C, where the object is held in the down position. C and A are
identical, the same down position, they're just different locations on the
timeline. The bird is held in place while the time is between C and A. Here's a
graph of time versus the drinking bird's angle. With our initial drinking bird
animation, the end of the swing backwards is particularly unconvincing. The
bird abruptly stops and moves forward again. With linear interpolation you get
just that, linear motion. As you transition from one pair of keyframes to
another the motion can suddenly change. To make the transition look smoother
its common to use spline curves of various sorts to change the motion from
keyframe to key frame. You'll also see the terms ease in or ease out which
means to start or end the animation gradually from a stop. 3JS has an add-on
library called Tween.min.js that let's you set up a series of keyframes. With
this library, here's my attempt to improve the drinking bird by using five
keyframes total. I added an extra two keyframes at the end to get a wobble.
You'll get to take a closer look and critique it in a minute.